anyway CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is with us Jill good morning
good morning a 13 digit value mark can
they keep this up well I guess that they
can keep it up for as long as the market
is there they've got great products one
thing that really has happened that's
different under Tim Cook than his
predecessor Steve Jobs he has been a
much more involved CEO with the
financial management of this company
buying back shares declaring dividends
and he's also obviously trying to expand
the services part of Apple when they
don't have a killer product they even
had a killer product since 2007 when the
iPhone was released but I would never
bet against Apple with all due respect
to that man mr. Wayne
let's talk about how and why Apple has
such a large market cap the market value
of Bank of America
Boeing AT&T Walt Disney Volkswagen and
Ford combined is about equal to that of
Apple is it a good thing for a company
to be that big sometimes when you get so
big you lose some creativity that was
some kind of the rap wouldn't Tim Cook
took over in 2011 how are they going to
actually move forward and they're gonna
lose their design elements are they
going to be less creative but I would
also point out this is a trend in
technology stocks specifically and the
broader market we refer to something
called the Fang stocks it's Facebook
Apple Amazon Netflix and Google parent
alphabet now you look at those five
stocks they account for about half of
the S&P 500 index is gains for the year
so this is a domination of technology
and within tech huge firms continue to
dominate at least until regulated it's
not an artificial high though if it's
just five companies that are keeping the
market where it is well it's not
artificial it is the numbers of the
numbers but we know that if those
companies stumble we could see a big
reaction across the whole market and its
peak jelly view back to the last giant
in this country which was GM they had
600,000 employees Apple has 120,000 what
did that tell us about where we are I
think it tells us that service and even
product developers are finding much
cheaper ways to put their their goods
out to the marketplace and incrementally
all that money that actually is saved on
labor falls to the bottom line so who
gets that money shareholders so we
talked about the difference between
shareholders getting value and labor
getting value in this case it's a great
illustration labor is on the short end
of the stick doesn't mean that Apple
doesn't have well-paid people just not a
lot of them right oh thank you